hey everybody I just saw Hotel
Transylvania 3 and to give you a little
recap and what I think of the other two
films before it uh I absolutely love
them I know they don't get the best
reviews uh I think they're hilarious I
think they're beautifully animated I
think the characters are great I think
they're creative
I think the comedy is super fast I think
it's super funny I think it's that
they're really good movies in my pan
like I know they're not like ground
breakers or anything like that I mean
they're just straightforward comedies
but I mean as Halloween straightforward
comedies go I think these are insanely
funny and you can take kids to them as
well and I just I can't go on more about
how I love the first two movies I I
watch him every Halloween they always
get me in the Halloween mood I know a
lot of other people do too so uh I very
much enjoy those first two films and
that brings us does third one released
in summer we you know there's a joke
that Sandler kind of almost admitted to
that he makes movies can't just to go on
vacation you know like it again whether
or not he was joking about or not I mean
I open for debate whatever but you know
there was always this joke that some of
these movies are so bad because you know
he's going on vacation and here it's an
animated movie or they're going on a
cruise or going on vacation you don't
need to it's animated you're not
shuffling anywhere but that's that's
something else maybe people just thought
they wanted to get him out of the hotel
and again they wanted a summer theme for
some reason even though again it's
mostly at night it's mostly in the dark
it's clearly a Halloween ish movie but
whatever so this movie is about the
Hotel Transylvania characters going on a
cruise and you know of course coming
across all sorts of high jinks and
terrible things trying to get them and
this one's not as good as the other two
I can't say it's bad because there are
still a lot of jokes that that work and
made me laugh and I think you can still
take kids to it fine and there's not
many moments where like I'm cringing or
anything like that but there were a
couple oh there were a couple but again
one of the advantages of these movies is
that the humor is so fast so if a joke
doesn't work they quickly move on to the
other one so it's not
something where they leave like a really
long pause for the audience to laugh or
anything like that or if if they did
it's not really memorable it doesn't
like you know leaving it back down yet
but the there's a few big problems with
this movie the first one is I know the
first two films don't have like every
joke works like I get that there there's
some that don't work very well but again
they just move on to the next one very
quickly and with the first film I say
like 85% of both the jokes and the
emotional moments really hit bull's eyes
like they're just done incredibly well
the second film right goes down a bit
maybe like 75 80 you know percent of
them work this one's like is 60 to 65%
work now with that said there's a lot of
comedies we're like 10 percent you know
you can like name the jokes you laugh
down like two fingers and that's not
like this there's a lot of jokes that
work and there's a lot of creativity but
a lot of them for whatever reason just
we're not we're not hitting and I think
a big part of that is that the jokes did
not seem as character-driven there is
still character in this but it kind of
seemed more like they have so many
characters now where it kind of seems
like let's just fit in you know as many
as we can and some of the lines they say
don't even seem like lines a character
would say the the bit what a couple big
examples the black ass name but Mavis
his husband is practically pointless
throughout this film until the end where
they give him a little something to do
but you kind of forget he's even there
and he was like a major part of the
first two movies some of the other
characters you know just they almost
kind of blend together like the
Frankenstein monster and the mummy and
the Invisible Man that they almost they
all cast seem like one character now
like they don't seem to have like very
distinct separate identities they're all
kind of there to make some of these
other jokes work or not work um but I'll
get to my biggest problem with this
movie is that as someone that loves
animation well I loved about the first
two Hotel Transylvania films is that the
animation did have a lot of energy to it
but every character had a distinct kind
of movement and I think there's a
difference between a style and just
doing the exact same thing for everybody
and in the first movie if you compare
how Dracula moves compared to someone
like how the mummy moves you know the
Dracula you know is he's very properiy
he's upright and usually like the upper
half of his body is not doing much but
his lower half is doing something like
he'll be hunched over like this totally
still but the lower half will be going
like this or if he's like crouching
through somewhere or it is running he'll
like be like this but his feet will be
going like this you'll see the
background zooming past and you know
stuff like that is very distinctive how
someone like a mavis will move maybe
this movie you know but very feminine
very sleek very smooth or the
Frankenstein monster he's very big so
he'll move very grand and very huge or
the mummy they'll move you know he's
more round so he'll move sort of with
more curves and sort of this weird
distinct way and I think there's
definitely this way of moving that these
movies have where you know characters
will suddenly move very quickly this and
in the first two films eels balanced out
just enough here every character moves
like that all the time and they all move
the same I think the best example I can
give you it's actually in the trailer is
they're all gonna go scuba diving if
this shots only for like a second but I
mean it's like it just got Bruce what
I'm talking about
you have Mavis or husband Dracula some
other character I can't remember who but
they're all the got their scuba gear on
and they're all gonna go scuba diving
all of them walk the exact same way and
super exaggerated and they're hunched
over like this they have their arms out
like this they're going like this and
their feet are going like that and I
guess the idea they're trying to do is
like whoa when you have you know scuba
gear on you're gonna walk a little weird
but all of them walk like how maybe this
is husband would walk maybe it's one
walk like that
Dracula wouldn't walk like that and it's
that style throughout the whole thing
and it's very distracting you know when
when it you you just want to hear a joke
you just want focus on what they're
saying but you're distracted by the fact
that every single time they talk it's
always like
it's like this super William Shatner way
that he doesn't family guy you know it's
that kind of movement throughout the
whole thing and you know they introduced
a new character who again this is in the
trailer is the like the
great-granddaughter of Van Helsing which
is a great idea that's very very funny
uh and she just kind of moves like
everyone else I mean here's a new
character you introduced and you can you
know give her a very distinct movement
you know even the the great grandfather
and this is kind of this weird robotic
guy and he's he has a distinct movement
cuz he says were a little robot but even
he kind of does the same movements the
more thing about it uh but she just kind
of moves like how everyone else moves it
and I think what real one of the things
that really drew me to the other films
is that even though again they're not
like phenomenally character driven but I
mean they're that's still kind of the
focus everyone has their own distinct
identity and movement and it's really
all blending together here and I think
that's surprisingly what made a lot of
those jokes work in the first two films
even though not all of them work it's
still what gave it its charm and I think
that's kind of what's missing here a lot
of the charm is gone and it's not
replaced with comedy funny enough to
fill that void um but with that said uh
there are still a few emotional moments
there there are a few moments where can
slow down and light like Dracula like I
like this idea that Dracula is looking
for someone else to be with he's looking
you know he's feeling lonely and you see
him try to go on to day do you see him
try to be nice and but the person he's
trying to date is trying to kill him
like this this is a great idea and they
do take time to get a little emotional
to slow it down and I like those moments
but there's not many and a lot of it is
just kind of replaced with this kind of
generic slapstick that has you know
again sometimes works and sometimes
they'll throw in like even a little
surreal humor like the two little kids
in this again who feel very you know
underutilized are trying to sneak in
this gigantic dog and the dog is just
like you know any other dog you know the
the tongue and barking and stuff like
that and when they have to sneak them in
they have them on
they haven't just in this big coat and a
hat and they say this is Bob say hi Bob
and the dog suddenly just goes hi Bob
and walks in and you have no idea how
that's possible like that jokes like
that are great and I there's a couple
like then there's a couple just serve
bumbum jokes that work too but like I
said it's very half and half and when
they don't work it's not awful
you're just you're really wishing it
worked it worked so well on the other
two films uh and then we get to this is
the one super cringy moment in this
movie and sadly it's like it's in the
climax and it's like it's supposed to be
like the big moment of the movie and it
just I don't know the audience I saw
with was not feeling it like was not
laughing or anything and I won't give
away that everything about it but pretty
much the setup is it's kind of a musical
climax where they have to use songs
against each other and one of them has
to they have to come up with a way to do
this they need like a positive song and
they're playing all sorts of different
songs and stuff and finally they're
building up like they're actually
building up to this one song at the end
they say we really need something
positive just an incredible beat an
incredible song to defeat the evil
negativity or whatever so they're really
building this up and what's so funny is
that there's so many other songs you
could choose because they built it up so
much that could probably get a laugh the
song they choose is baffling like I'm
amazed they went with this because not
only is it is it old it's an older song
but it's it's not even old like in a
retro kind of way like people are like
oh yeah I remember that I want to get
into that ha ha
you got me they're like okay a good
example like is in Beetlejuice when they
sing when they sing do you know I mean
that's first of all that's so bizarre
and so out of nowhere and it's already a
timeless song that it gets a lap and
it's just so strange it rides the
strangeness of it where if they did like
a more modern song at that time and oh
that would have worked uh here it's like
it's not weird enough it's not relevant
enough it's not funny enough it's just
it's the most pretty much the most
Awkward song you could choose in my
opinion and they do a whole big song and
dance number around it and everyone's
just doing it not ironically they're
dancing oh yeah this this is good this
is good and it's just it's a real
head-scratcher I'm not gonna lie uh so
that was like the one moment that was
super cringy where I just feel like meh
who made that choice I'm wondering if
you know and maybe it's just kind of the
older guy in me I mean maybe I just
missed the joke but when I saw it
everyone was just like even when you
heard the song start like you know you
hear the first few knows you know what
it's gonna be and that like if they're
doing it like haha like you should be
laughing now we played those first few
notes you know what this song is and
nobody was laughing uh nobody was really
getting into it so um yeah I don't know
I don't know if I just went over my head
or maybe it is really retro and the
songs gonna be this moment is gonna be a
huge hit but yeah man I wasn't feeling
it so uh with that said do I regret
seeing it no I'm still glad I saw it
because I like these movies and I like
showing support for these movies
especially one of the critics don't for
whatever reason and but this one it's
like I I saw once probably won't see it
again I don't think I'm gonna buy it on
blu-ray or anything like that like I can
watch those or two movies over and over
and over I'm I'm glad I saw this one uh
you know there's so few jokes that work
especially like it when the the wolf man
and his wife drop off the kids that kind
of like the daycare on the ship and
they've never had that before then you
just see what they do with their spare
time and they're just so not used to not
having kids you know so it's like stuff
like that is great and again that comes
from their character I think that's
where that works any of the jokes that
still come directly from the characters
I think are usually pretty solid
any jokes you know around the monster
stuff is also okay but any kind just
generic slapstick stuff you know just
saw someone get hit so they can get hit
or something huh a lot of them just
didn't they just didn't hit it funny
enough see how slapstick but okay so so
what I recommend it if you like the
first two films and you're you're
curious enough like you know if you like
them enough that you feel like yeah I
know it's not gonna be that hot but I
just like I like this world I like these
characters I say still go check it out
you probably don't need to see it on the
big screen you can probably rent it but
but I say go see it it's not offensive
you know there's definitely Adam Sandler
films that are offensive but yeah this
one it's a serious downgrade but that
doesn't necessarily make it down here
it's not super bad and like I said I
would not actually say it's you know I
regret seeing it I'm glad I did but it
is a downgrade I'm not gonna see it
again you can take your kids to see it
find there's a lot of slaps taking a lot
of goofy stuff honestly too much last in
all honesty but you know it doesn't
really bounce out but yeah if you're
looking for something take your kids
your kids want to see it it's totally
fine there's nothing ethically bad in it
or anything like that if you're an adult
and you like the first two movies you'll
probably get enough laughs out of this
but you'll probably see what I'm talking
about - it is kind of a downgrade so go
check it out tell me what you think let
me know if I'm just a pain in the ass
just looking for things to complain
about or a bit legit he's kind of lower
on the totem pole so that's about it
I'll talk to you next time later
you